so how long before
you had this first owl experience have
you been sort of intrigued or
interested in ufos well
i as a boy as a 12 year old boy i was
walking home from a high school football
game so the high school football
field was close to the my house and it
was what all the kids did on a friday
night so
and this would have been october i was
living in michigan it was a beautiful
night i was walking home with a friend
and i wanted to be home in time to see a
television series do you know the tv
show coal shack the night stalker
i've heard of it but i've never seen it
it was a predecessor to the x-files it
was about a
reporter who you know looks at ghosts
and zombies and
vampires and stuff like that and uh so i
i um we got to a point in the
neighborhood
and there was this bright orange flash
in the sky
and we both said the same thing we both
kind of went what just happened
and and all i saw was this orange flash
it felt like god flipped a light switch
click
the sky turned bright orange click just
went back to normal night
like everything the whole sky turned
bright orange there was no noise then we
went through the little checklist could
it have been like a meteorite could it
have been like a telephone pole
exploding could it have been a plane
crash did something
none of it made sense it was totally
quiet it was and it was jarring it was
really weird we both were like
that didn't seem right so i got to my
house he went further into the
neighborhood i got home and my
parents were waiting for me and i walked
in the door and i said
they said why are you out so late they
were angry at me i said i'm not out late
i said i'd be home at 9 30 i'm home at 9
30 to see the television show that
starts at 10 o'clock
and they pointed at the clock and it was
11 30.
so somewhere i lost two hours of time
between an hour and a half to two hours
of time
now if you've read stuff in the ufo
literature like that kind of thing is a
is a telltale sign and that's what a ufo
investigator
kind of keeps her eye out for that's a
red flag that something else happened
this was 1974. i i didn't know any of
that
so i was just bummed out that i didn't
see this television show and i was
really like annoyed that my parents were
mad at me for something i didn't do
like i didn't understand why i was out
so late
so the next monday morning at school
we're sitting around
with my friend and and uh
there's a bunch of kids at the cafeteria
table and i said this weird thing
happened on friday night
and my friend interrupts and said yeah
we saw ufo with lights and everything
can i swear on the show oh yeah
absolutely so he said 12 year old boy
and he said we saw you off with a he
said we saw a ufo with [ __ ] lights
and everything
and i was in him i remember thinking
like i didn't see a ufo i just saw the
sky turn orange
i've since contacted him and he does not
remember the event he does remember that
my mom was angry at me for coming home
late
so that's that is actually not uncommon
within the literature so
or the literature of like ufo studies
that um
two witnesses will have two separate
things so
so that's one story uh beforehand before
seeing the owls did you ever tell
anybody about this that doesn't mean
that remembers when you told them about
it oh like do they remember like you
telling the story prior to the whole owl
you know what i have is i i i have a i
drew a picture of hey i'll get to
so that story my friend remembers that
my my uh mom was angry or my parents
were angry
and um but yeah i don't that's hard to
know that was that's
getting close to 35 years ago 40 years
ago now so
but um so i don't have any evidence of
that i do
i did see a i was at a friend's house
his name is kenny and
we it was a sleepover i was 12 years old
it was probably right around the same
time
and he he pointed out the window it
might have been him or me pointed out
the window
like what's that and we went to the
window and there was a this is actually
interesting we have a can here
so there was a like a coffee can shaped
thing
and it was rotating at this really weird
angle and
and sort of descending actually was more
like
it's more like i can't remember yeah it
was descending and rotating at the same
time it had like a pencil sticking out
the top of this thing
and we watched it for maybe 30 seconds
and then it just disappeared poof gone i
used to say the lights went out and we
couldn't see it anymore i don't say that
anymore because i was because that's not
true what i remember clearly is that it
disappeared it vanished but i was like
too embarrassed to say that
like at the time as a 12 year old boy so
i said the lights just turned out
i drew a picture of that that same night
and um i contacted
the fellow with kenny and he also
doesn't remember it
but he said his mother he talked to his
mom and his mother remembers us
drawing it he and i both drew it and i
still have the picture that we drew that
night
after seeing the coffee can shape craft
do you have any of these
uh drawings published on your website
yep all of them published my website
let's pull up his website so we can
actually show some of this stuff they'll
probably be a good idea what's it what's
your website called
um hidden experience
it's all one word and then the
image of the coffee can thing would be
out kenny's window that would be the
there's a little
search box on the right hand side bar
you can type in out kenny's window
and it should pop right up that'll be
good if we're talking about things
whatever we can pull up some of the
illustrations on your website
and your friends that you were sleeping
over with there do they remember this
experience
no i only talked to kenny this kenny
kenny doesn't remember or he does he
does not remember he's not remember but
his mother remembers us drawing it and i
he'll steal the drawing yeah you can see
on the on the right hand side bar scroll
down a little bit
um and there you can search this blog
you can just type in
you can type in out kidneys window if
you just hope you just went back go go
up to the right there
right on the right a little right hand
side bar no down below that right there
yeah out kenny's window
yeah there we go so there's the image so
that's a that's an updated drawing that
i did recently
okay and then scroll down on that jordan
oh you can double click it and it'll
show up big
okay yeah so that's um
that's a drawing i did recently that
that captures what i saw
but if you scroll down back to the blog
there um there's an image that i drew
uh oh there's sort of a strange motion
there was an accompanying little
dot of light a pinpoint of light that
that oh keep on going down it should
there we go there's the drawing i did
that night so you you drew this the same
night you saw it
yep within minutes both kenny and i
kenny doesn't have it so yeah you can
double click on that it'll grow up big
um okay that's fine so um
but uh so there was an accompanying
little dot of light in the sky
so you can see that i'm kind of it's the
dots are numbered one two three
so when those little dots are kind of
like blink blink blink those dots were
not
exceptional that would have looked just
like an airplane in the night sky we
nothing unusual about those dots
but when those that dot like the coffee
can was descending the dot was
traversing across the sky
when those two met up that's when it
disappeared
wow so so ever since those two
experiences you've kind of been
intrigued by
ufos by ufo phenomenon i've certainly
been intrigued i didn't start going
around 1992 or three
i started i got a ufo book i just bought
it
i said well i'll just this is a topic
that interests me and it was the book
was fascinating
it was called the ufo case book by um
randalls the author's name is randalls
and then um
and then i bought another one i bought
another one and also that was all i was
reading
and that's so that's almost whatever
30 years 25 years ago 30 years ago to
1990
yeah 1992. so um
and there's one more story which i also
did an illustration for
um
i and i was 30 years old i was living in
maine in 1992
which was interesting was about the same
time i started reading ufo books
and i woke up in the middle of the night
i was alone at the house and
i it felt like there was a bright light
coming in the window now we had a deer
motion sensor light out in the driveway
and i kind of thought like what's the
bright light and i sat up
on my elbow and looked out the window
and there were five
gray aliens walking towards the house
and they were backlit
by a bright white light
and that i have an illustration of that
if you want to bring it up to you yeah
yeah type in um uh
bedroom window it should come right up
in that little box
gray aliens so the typical prototypical
gray alien is the one you see on like
the snowboarder bumper stickers and
stuff like that it's right
there skinny little being so yeah you
can double click that that should get
big holy cow
so that's and i did have a little
dinosaur on my um
i did have a little dinosaur on my uh
you did have it yeah
and and they were and so they looked
just like that they were they were
standing in a perfect line like
you know it was funny they actually were
walking on the snow and i
i tried to draw them walking and it
distracted from it so
it looked like they were trying to dance
or something okay but they were all in a
line like that
like to try to draw them walking was a
little awkward so they were actually
walking but i drew them standing
and they would have been walking now
that light in the background would have
been about
the size of a washing machine you know
like it would have been perfect it was
like a landed flying saucer but that's
not what i that's not my memory
and now
it's okay if i just go on about this
because this oh yeah okay okay
so um please
this this accompanying this
like like i got up the next morning
dismissed it completely as a dream
right so i but when i saw this out the
window
i looked at this thing this is scary
right this should have been i should
have like jumped out of bed i should
have like locked the doors i should have
like grabbed a knife and defended myself
i didn't
i heard a voice in my head that said
very calmly
now is the time to put your head on the
pillow and shut down
and that's exactly what i did i just
i just rolled over and went to sleep
what also accompanied that moment was
this
sensation it was dream-like but i don't
but it wasn't a dream
i don't i feel strongly that it was not
a dream but it was certainly dream like
there was a weird clarity there was a
weird quietness to it
there was this sort of head in the
fishbowl quality to it
um i have since talked to many this was
this this i couldn't i didn't have any
place for this memory
this experience i i could not place this
i just like so nope
not going to deal with this this was a
dream i'm not going there
and but since then i have talked to so
many other ufo witnesses or witnesses
that have had close-up sightings
i talked to one woman and she described
seeing a ufo from a car she was like on
la on a street in l.a and a flying
saucer flew over her car and got
right above her and she has some
distorted time stuff with that with that
event
and she said to me she said you know
when you have two magnets
and you try to push them together they
go click and you pull them apart and you
switch one halfway and then you try to
push them together they won't they won't
they'll sort of
push against each other this is kind of
warbly sort of energy where they
she said being that close to the ufo
that flying saucer was like
being in between the two magnets in that
warbly
weird energy and when she said that it
was like
she knows she knows that's exactly what
it felt like
like that was the that's the best
description i've ever had of that
of that sensation within the literature
that's often referred to as the oz
factor
it's not that the not that the scene is
quiet it's that it's too quiet
it's like oh it's like all the sound is
sucked out
so so i was seeing that out my window i
had this distorted sense of reality
and i have felt that a few more times in
other experiences but that to me
was the was the part i couldn't dismiss
i could dismiss it as a dream i don't
really dream that i'm in my own bedroom
right i don't dream that i sit up in my
own bed i'm always in some other place
in my dreams but that night i
i felt like i sat up in bed i saw that
out the window it probably lasted
20 seconds and then i heard the voice in
my head that said
now is the time to put on your put your
head on the pillow and shut down
and and the next morning i never even
bothered to go out look if there were
footprints in the snow
so